les dirigeants ukrainiens le perçoivent
avec le plus grand méfiance volodymyr
élèves qui a dit oui il ya des signaux
positifs venant des pourparlers en
turquie et de cette annonce faite par la
russie mais comment est ce qu'on peut
croire la parole à ses dirigeants russes
qui ont évidemment tellement menti et
qui poursuivent leur campagne militaire
à différents endroits du pays pendant la
nuit c'était plus bruyants que
d'habitude en réalité mais ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que les russes n'ont
pas promis de retirer leurs forces des
terres qu'ils occupent en ce moment et
les ukrainiens continue de contre
attaquer sur des villes comme boston l
ucia irin que les ukrainiens affirment
avoir repris est encore en réalité la
scène de bataille assez intense donc les
combats continuent mais de l'autre côté
il y a des forces russes qui se retirent
ils ont même été photographié en
biélorussie mais de l'avis des
militaires ukrainien c'est plutôt pour
se regrouper et préparer de nouvelles
attaques qui pourraient être dans la
direction de kiev pour essayer
d'encercler la capitale pour les
ukrainiens il n'y a vraiment pas
d'évidence concrètes sur le terrain que
les russes aient vraiment changé de
stratégie et qu' ils ont vraiment
renoncé à cette idée d'encercler kiev et
de prendre aussi czernik est une ville
importante qui est encerclée qui était
au nom de kiev certains experts
militaires dont on avait un peu plus
optimiste cependant ils disent à
l'institut pour l'étude de la guerre par
exemple que peut-être effectivement les
russes ont constaté qu'ils ne sont pas
capables tout simplement d'encercler et
de prendre cap est donc effectivement
ils vont changer de stratégie parce que
ils vont tes tenté de faire des choses
qui sont possibles mais cela reste à
voir dans les semaines qui viennent
bonjour du lit vers l'ukraine de son
côté a fait une série de propositions
hier en turquie notamment autour de
cette question de la neutralité comment
est ce qu'il faut comprendre ces
propositions
alors l'ukraine ne propose une
neutralité officielle mais avec des
garanties de sécurité offerte par ses
alliés est en quelque sorte je ne sais
pas si les russes font vraiment accepter
cela comme une vraie neutralité cela
reste à voir mais à partir du moment où
on a des promesses et les freins dit
qu'elle veut des promesses qui serait
analogue à la l'article 5 du traité de
l'otan comme quoi les autres pays
interviendrait en soutien de l'ukraine
en cas d'agression contre l'ukraine mais
officiellement elle serait neutre et
donc l n'adhérait pas à l'otan ce qui
est ce qu'ils étaient avant cette
invasion à l'une des demandes les plus
importantes de vladimir poutine
l'ukraine dit vouloir aussi un pouvoir
accéder au marché commun de l'union
européenne rejoindre le marché unique de
l'union européenne
rapidement et il l a fait aussi une
proposition sur la crimée de congés la
situation sur la crimée pendant 15 ans
avant d'en parler et le négociateur en
chef de l'ukraine s'est vraiment réjoui
du fait que la russie n'a pas rejeté
cette proposition dont blé ils ont
peut-être prêt
à parler de la crimée du statut de la
crimée dans 15 ans